hey guys welcome to the first Rubin
report of 2015 I have Kim hjortur and
brett erlich with me and we have an
insane amount to get to including some
breaking news so here we go
there was a horrific attack in Paris
just within the last couple hours and
we've got some video from ABC News ten
minutes after noon a quiet Paris side
street when a car pulled up gunmen
jumped out and according to eyewitness
video which you will see and here opened
fire with automatic weapons and if you
listen closely the gunmen holler out
Allahu Akbar as they fire upon this
weekly satirical newspaper that had a
long history of tweaking all religions
including Islam the newspaper had been
fire bombed before for publishing those
infamous cartoons of the Prophet
Muhammad this was a much more deadly
attack that was actually a police
officer guarding that paper that officer
was killed as you say there are 11 more
dead ok so this story is still unfolding
as we record this right now these images
obviously we're seeing this stuff just
every day so we're gonna show you a
couple covers from the Charlie Hebdo
newspapers so they were an equal a true
equal opportunity offender here they are
with the Pope so that's obviously a
knock on Christianity here's what
appears to be a Orthodox Jew I wish my
French was better so I could understand
that I see Palestine in there and then
of course the next one is Mohammed now
obviously the Danish cartoon incident
which I think was in 2011 caused a lot
of craziness I feel like we're becoming
just so insanely desensitized to this
stuff like I woke up this morning I see
a zillion tweets about it you watch
another video people screaming shots and
it's just like well it happened in
Australia two weeks ago France they've
been having all kinds of problems over
the last couple years anyway like how
desensitized are you to this kind of
stuff I remember back when South Park
did this and it was or was a Family Guy
yeah I don't remember who did what but I
definitely have seen a Family Guy
with Mohammed in it yeah they both they
both have had Mohammed in yeah it was a
throw away and the South Park made fun
of them they're like well we're gonna
revenge on America and they made their
own cartoon or like I'm a third American
I have babies out of wedlock you darling
it was back then we thought oh it's so
you know it's so satirical and funny and
original but maybe you're right maybe we
are a little desensitized to it now yeah
what do you think first of all how do
you know that looks like Mohammad it
looked exactly the same as the comic
before it yeah it looked like the Jews
right that's so how do we know it's not
a Jew dressed up like his friend
Muhammad that's another thing we need to
clarify and I'm sure Jesus had a friend
named Muhammad yeah for sure I'm just
saying like the whole idea is there were
never any photos of Muhammad or drawings
nor depictions images so so we don't
know if that really is what he looks
like I think it's just so right but
that's so prism it's so presumptuous and
so frustrating on the part of these
militants they need to understand
outside of outside of their little world
that there's this whole big world but
they just don't give a [ __ ] like I get
it I get that and I see that already on
Twitter people are trying like
rationalize it in a weird way but I
don't understand why especially people
on the left that should be for free
speech like they just don't give a [ __ ]
so what are we don't give a [ __ ] in
terms they don't like they can listen to
you and be like oh well brett erlich
said that there's a bigger world out
there and we should respect other
people's beliefs but that's not in the
very belief system yeah here's the thing
it's like no one's gonna come to defense
of the comedians I don't think that's
the problem and all the comedians like
wait we should be able to tell jokes
[ __ ] ran let's pay attention right now
but don't you think about it like who's
this isn't like a school of people was
bombed and even when a school of
children is bombed people do move on
it's such a it's such a difficult
impasse that we're at I'd honestly don't
know right that's actually a good point
because I even when I preface this story
I totally skipped over what happened in
Pakistan literally two weeks ago with
100 something dead children so isn't
that like the most perverse part of this
that they're attacking basically this
magazine is the equivalent of the onion
in France so this is a true direct
attack on free speech like in a weird
way this is this is sort of the worst
thing they could do right do you feel
that we're maybe giving them too much
leeway and rationalization in that way
like oh well this is just what they do
and we we need
work around it I don't think anyone
wants to work around it it's just we
don't know how to work through it yeah
like that's the problem I mean yeah I
mean that's the dangerous people get it
feels like lazy and they're just like oh
whatever
I mean well they're yeah let's what are
we gonna do tomorrow but but I honestly
don't know how to engage it and I do
think that if we I'm giving them a
probably as much credit as they deserve
in that this is part of their tactic
this is the death by a thousand cuts
this is you know either I mean we can't
like bomb Paris by and large we need to
go do all these little attacks so that
it's more just this nebulous feeling of
dread that you have yeah you go
terrorism works right so do you think
what they want ultimately is for the
French authorities and the French
government then to start cracking down
on freedom of speech even more becoming
more afraid of allowing to show images
like this thus they don't even have to
do it like that sort of that's sort of
the brilliance of terrorism in a weird
way they don't have to take away your
freedoms through terror they just force
the government to start restricting your
freedoms themselves also I think part of
the strategy it depends on who's
perpetrating this but if if the strategy
is to establish an Islamic state this is
part of the tactic the part of the
strategy this is the tactic that gets
you to focus on Paris and not you know
the Middle East right so now we're we're
we're playing defense on our own turf
this is taking the fight to France so
that France won't necessarily be more
inclined the more attacks are
perpetrated on the streets of France the
less inclined the French government will
be to not necessarily police around
Paris in terms of like free speech but
more like contribute to the effort to
put down Isis yeah do you guys think
that in a weird way this actually might
sort of help look in America we have a
different free speech than they have in
in Europe they don't have free sif they
don't have the First Amendment the way
we have it here like people right well
they don't have it fully you're not
allowed to deny the Holocaust there's
different there's different hate speech
rules things like that but do you think
in a weird way this actually sort of the
reverse question of what I asked a
second ago that this actually may sort
of help the the freedom fighters the
people that believe in free speech and
the satirist and the comedians because I
just on Twitter already in the last hour
the amount of people that I saw that
we're posting the cartoon and saying
[ __ ] this we can't be tolerant of
intolerance so we
so in a weird way they actually might be
strengthening the people that they're
trying to unintentionally for sure I
mean certainly the intended effect is
free to be like oh I'm scared okay we
better not do this then we better like
do what they want yeah and that's the
natural thing to move in but clearly
that's what the desired effect is of
these terrorists so no yeah
all right well certainly there's no
answer to that and this since this thing
is still unfolding we will find out the
world is coming to an end people but
fear not CNN is going to walk us through
it that's right some video leaked I
guess this week showing what CNN has
planned for when the world comes to an
end but before we get to the video let's
look at a statement from CNN's Ted
Turner barring satellite problems we
won't be signing off until the world
ends we'll be on and we will cover the
end of the world live and that will be
our last event we'll play the national
anthem only one time on the first of
June the day CNN launched and when the
end of the world comes we'll play nearer
my God to thee before we sign off okay
so that's what he said originally when
they came up with this idea that the
world was gonna end in that they'd have
to do a little quick programming so now
let's watch the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I know if the world was anything that's
how I would want to spend my last
minutes watching that look you know
media outlets they have to prepare for
[ __ ] right there are obituaries for
everybody over 50 that they have stock
stuff ready to go every now and again
you see them get leaked online it'll be
like not to be published and they
accidentally reveal that someone's died
and they haven't all that so I guess
this is just them doing their due
diligence no I used to work for a news
company and we did have obituaries
things that we would use in case of
there was a natural disaster but you
know then that would lead into a live
reporter doing something that is more
timely it was funny cuz I saw it said
HFR which is like news feed for hold for
release end of the world hey wait what
do we want maybe an updated film file of
better quality yeah ending I mean let's
do it right like have they updated that
is the question Jeff Zucker took over
CNN did he say guys you know let's
update the end of the world doing hip
hop write something it's the late 90s
and then it's like oh here we go
Katy Perry's thinking nearer my God to
thee like what that's where we have now
that's what we how we should do it every
every few years we need to update
definitely not be like for it's in a
four by three the original video yeah
and like how about that ambient noise by
the way we have a noise canceling audio
programs now where we can get rid of
that low rumble in the remind you of
something that would air maybe like in a
disaster movie yes sort of flickering TV
as the embers of society burn out is
everybody looks like the beginning of a
commercial on the first day of MTV
before like Sammy Hagar yeah but there
was another thing I thought about this
but I forgotten it well that's alright
what are you gonna do when the world
ends like the idea that anyone would be
sitting there you know the world and so
let's look the world's ending so I
assume this means aliens are attacking
or global warming but if it's global
warming that's gonna happen slowly so
this strikes me more as like we know
what comets coming you got five minutes
left
you're not gonna be watching TV wouldn't
you what would you do
at the end you got five minutes left
zombies I have sword training I'm gonna
go out there and I'm gonna live
you'd be the Michonne of our network
maybe yeah you would I believe that
she'd definitely be the Michonne you
would be the gonna be the first you did
the little girl who's like going like
this in the first scene you know like I
would be that I was gonna pay first I
was gonna peg you as the scientist with
the mullet I don't know yeah I know way
way back what would I do
five minutes left meteors come in the
aliens of the zombies I don't know take
vampires I think something ridiculous a
jerk-off that's yeah I'm probably just
make make you know I want to have a
little bit of pleasure the last few
minutes and what I like about this video
though is it's like there's so much
pressure not to play it before the
actual end of the world that I doubt
they'll ever get a chance to play well
that's the beauty like all hell's
breaking loose and like what are you
gonna send some PA or some intern don't
forget to press the button on the like
that's who I am
right I'm is it Wolf Blitzer Wolf
Blitzer is gonna press the button
Blitzer you know I Blitzer I'm carrying
him up to the camera and then I'm slowly
crawling toward the tape get it in there
get it in there to make sure it plays
before the world ends so dramatic yes so
dramatic indeed all right let's move on
have you seen the show strange
addiction' we've talked about it a bit
before and the clips everything that
they do goes viral because they get
clips of people that like to eat toilet
paper there was a woman who I think was
in love with her couch then we saw this
one which I thought was kind of
interesting this is about female maskers
okay you have to put in a lot of powder
so you don't stick to it and this is why
I do it over the bathtub so it doesn't
make a big mess in my bathroom you look
amazing
that's why I do this because I think so
too I just can't believe that that's a
70 year old man in the mirror and that's
why I do this if I saw a 70 year old man
in the mirror I quit this tomorrow what
do you see when you look in the mirror
not very exciting female if I were to
see a regular woman like this and she
would say come on let's hang out I'd say
okay let's go hang out this just blows
my hair back that I can do this that's
be in there that's that's one of the
things I have to keep telling myself
that's not just a seven year old man
that's me inside that female okay so if
you aren't exactly clear what a female
master is at this point I'll give you
the exact definition it is men who like
to wear rubber and silicone body suits
to resemble life-size shapely female
dolls look guys dress like women that's
sort of accepted at this point it used
to be like sort of a big joke I guess
but that's kind of accepted so is this
just the the next step of that I mean
it's I don't know like is it equally yes
or is it just lifestyle
it sounds pretty sexual it is like this
blows my hair back yeah there's a 70
year old man and I'm inside that woman I
just think okay it's not my king yeah
he's not hurting anyone and he's getting
fulfillment why not I know so when I was
looking at this story and when the
producer sounded to me I was kind of
thinking that's sort of what I was
thinking like everyone's into weird [ __ ]
people do all kinds of stuff so this guy
is doing this and yes it's really
bizarre and it also feels like Silence
of the Lambs doesn't it feel like
Buffalo Bill yeah that's what he was
trying to do right he was trying to
build he's the serial killer of late
cent of that right like he was trying to
build a woman suit to put around his
body exactly so I don't so again I don't
want it now I'm comparing him to a
fictitious serial murderer so I don't
quite yet but like it's not hurting
anyone is it is it bad to make fun of
this then because it's obvious like
there's obviously something funny
Brett clean it up my crazy fetish is to
tell jokes about things yeah and so I'm
going to tell jokes about this because
that's my kink then it's not sexual
really but it's something I get a lot of
pleasure out of yeah so he can't really
attack me for doing that yeah that's how
that's me being [ __ ] up so you wear
your lady clothes and that'll make fun
of it I think I think he's that I would
make fun of it if he wasn't so gorgeous
yeah that's the thing that's what gets
me is I there's nowhere to go with this
well-said right early how did we find
out about these people before reality TV
so that's that part that's the part that
I think is fascinating like this guy
could be your next-door neighbor right
he could you know work at the same place
you work and you wouldn't tell us I'm
working on it all right
but really like these people are there
everybody right like we don't know what
you know like this could be anybody this
guy now I really kept I feel like you
really think I'm doing that that's why
the producers sent me this no but it
could be anybody but what I think is
fascinating like to me like something
like that there would be a shame
involved in it like you know like you're
weird kink whatever gets you off like
there's a weird shame but yet these
people are doing it on reality TV so
there's something about reality TV here
also that that's kind of interesting I
accept drag and I accept furries this
isn't crazily far off from either of
those yeah can you explain what furries
are to the people who wear fur suits
it's not always necessarily sexual
sometimes it's like well I feel more
like I'm a fox and I'm more comfortable
I feel more in my own skin when I'm
wearing this fur suit yes there is sex
involved but it's I'm fine with it
bit of a furry oh yeah yeah yeah we'll
annotate to it no that is not what a
friend no no there's parts of it it felt
very uh
go to search for maroon5 stuffed animals
parody we're gonna annotate right above
your head right now awesome start waving
for a second it's right on Brett right
there there you go yeah anyway alright
well that's all I have to say about this
it wasn't anything groundbreaking I just
think it's kind of it's kind of
interesting and you have something why
what I was thinking is in building on
what you were talking about about before
reality TV you find out about this to be
shocking and to be there'd be shaming
involved I think that knowing that
reality TV telling us that there are
people like this out there with weird
kinks makes it less likely that when
someone does find out about it anything
physically harmful will happen to them
so that's interesting so is that the
ultimate redeeming thing of reality TV
which I've relentlessly and mercilessly
mock and we did a story last week about
how nobody's watching reality TV anymore
and that's actually great but is that
sort of the the good thing about it that
it is sort of exposing these things and
then people will be more okay with weird
[ __ ] right now we cuz we used to see
something different and we're afraid of
it and we kill it now we see something
different and it's hilarious and we
watch it and I think for the people who
are different that's at least a better
thing than being killed right how great
would it have been if you had been in a
silicon suit this whole time and right
now - and this is just like I'm a 70
year old man alright so we actually
haven't talked much about Isis over the
last couple weeks because there's been
all kinds of other news and now
obviously what just happened in France
but Isis is still up - a lot of really
really awful [ __ ] and of course we are
still in a war now in Syria that we have
no congressional authorization over but
we don't really talk about that but
anyway a couple of new images came out
that I thought were pretty disturbing
and the type of [ __ ] that people need to
see to understand really what's
happening there
this is Isis they are chopping off the
hand of a man who stole some stuff
that's all he stole some stuff so they
are chopping off his hand and so you can
see he's sitting in a chair he's got a
noose tied to his wrist and that's how
they pull the hand away after it's
chopped off next photo
Isis law demands that after a trial
alyssum of the criminals crimes be read
out front of in a crowd of men who have
been invited to watch before the
punishment is carried out so they're
they're doing
some chopping it's pretty awful there
are unblurred version by the way yeah we
we blurred this because we can't show it
it's really quite awful of course here's
the moment that they cut off his hand
then next yeah this is just a group of
yeah I mean this is just becoming the
norm in the places that they control
that these types of public executions
and on mutilations and all this awful
stuff this was about a week before where
a man was whipped for watching porn so
he's being publicly whipped for watching
porn we've got another one on that and
as is customary in the Islamic state
punishment propaganda the final
photograph appears to be a staged scene
where the victim is shown hugging the
Isis fighter who has just punished him
as an act of forgiveness so in a weird
way like as horrible as all the the
stuff that we're showing you is that
almost seems like the worst part of it
like then they're like oh thank you for
correcting my ways so I guess my first
question here is this sort of goes to
what I asked you in the France thing a
little while ago but does anything
shocked us anymore we've already seen
beheading 'z we've seen videos of
beheadings we've seen literally heads on
sticks I mean really horrific [ __ ] and
now this is just another extension of
the shop yeah that shocked me I don't
know what I'm gonna do about it but it
definitely is like what the [ __ ] are you
doing yeah like what is this is
accomplished move to the Islamic state
it's gorgeous here we'll cut your hand
off and smack you in the back in front
of your mom for watching porn and you
will thank us for it yeah
that's a good idea that's the parody
that you should be doing yeah is the
Tourism Board for Isis really are you
shocked by anything at this point
it was horrible and also you need to
think about I'm shocked that they think
that this is gonna stop people from
watching porn people watch porn and if
you look at the data a lot of these
countries are heavy consumers of
internet porn yeah not only they heavy
consumers of internet porn but I think
our fourth most watched country for this
show is Saudi Arabia which i think is
really kind of fascinating because
they're so insanely repressed even
though they are apparently a big ally of
the United States we give them a lot of
money we do all kinds of security stuff
for them sure women can't drive vote but
you know whatever but they can't drive
here am i right yeah
just a slight push it could have been a
full or smack mode so with all the crazy
[ __ ] that we have going on with our
police here and you know the
authoritative state and all that stuff
does this kind of put it a little bit
into perspective about how horrible the
world is yeah it does put it in
perspective that doesn't mean we
shouldn't stop like fighting no reports
more perfect union but yeah it does I
mean it's like I'm so happy that I live
here you know yeah I'm so happy that's
what I mean do we forget that a little
bit of course I'm not defending any
right surveillance state or any of that
[ __ ] which we relentlessly attack here
all the time but a little bit of that
did we forget like that we actually do
have it pretty good yes it's a [ __ ] up
system we have racial inequality and and
financial inequality all that but like
that it's still it's pretty good here
right it's like when you're and you go
to your Thanksgiving dinner and you're
like oh my family's crazy and then that
one time you're like out of town and you
go to someone else's you're like no
these people that's what it feels like
yeah I can't I can't imagine like anyone
wanting to you know what do we have in
America hopefully is like a country
people want to live in yeah and that's
you know for all the [ __ ] that's messed
up about it we kind of want to make it
cool yeah you know it's like we decorate
the place make it fancy but there it's
like Oh what is appealing about that
what is appealing about a place where
they cut your hand off and you don't
have a hand for the rest of your life
because you stole like something from
Blockbuster I don't know whatever the
equivalent is I'm sure it's a
blockbuster equivalent as opposed to a
Netflix like right do you have an answer
for that what what is it what is the
yeah but like I don't know for us I
don't we do have a prison system but in
that prison system it's like we don't
like cruel and unusual punishment
because like our gathering was weird we
have serious problems with our prison
system and absolutely prisoner
absolutely you know that does not
diminish with the knowledge that there
are horrible disgusting people doing
like just horrible things to other
people like that yeah
we are lucky in a sense but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't we should stop
striving to always be but no of course
of course I think that goes without
saying that of course we can do better
and we should do better and all that but
does it is do you take when you look at
this stuff like to me this is the irony
of America like everyone loves to hate
us and we love to you know make fun of
the system and all that but without us
Oh like when [ __ ] goes down everybody
also wants us there so is this like the
ultimate irony of American life I mean
yes that it is but like there's also
another interpretation of that where
it's like oh my god
America is a crazy neighbor with the gun
I don't want to have to go there at all
we don't want it we don't want to have
to talk to them we don't want to invite
them to dinner because they'll be like
well go shoot stuff in the backyard like
at least that's the perception of it
yeah so they that still doesn't mean
that I mean they need us cuz we got a
big gun but like that's it isn't
necessarily everything about us that
they that they like that led to that
right all right well can we at least all
agree that hand chopping off bad
whipping for poor and bad am i right can
mortar that's right unless that's part
of the porn and you like it you guys
know there's porn online apparently it's
true what they're both freaking out
looking the two of them but that's a
totally shock
I'll be back I'll be back in a second
gotta go check that out I like if you
were taking your shirt off apparently
all right well according to pornhub.com
their number one porn star is a 21 year
old Lebanese girl named Mia Khalifa
we've got some pictures of Mia there she
is
I think we've got one more so she grew
up in Lebanon but she moved to the
United States when she was a teenager
she now lives in Miami and she's a
student at Florida State University but
as her popularity from her fine work has
spread so to speak so has a lot of hate
coming on her from Lebanon and
throughout the Arab world so first up
we're gonna start with some of the the
hate tweets that she's getting okay so
the first tweet you're seeing here we
did not blur that out this person who
tweeted that deleted their account so
this is a screen grab from another
website what they're saying there is
[ __ ] wonders why Arabs bash on her
maybe because you [ __ ] degraded
in a porno you five-cent ho the next one
you do realize that you'll be the first
person in hellfire right and then third
Mia Khalifa is a disgrace to the Islam
religion what a sick person wears a
hijab during a porno now what they're
referring to there is that right there
where she is wearing a hijab now this
type of stuff happens in porn all the
time I'm pretty sure there's a lot of
porn about nuns and teachers and all
kinds of I can't corroborate yeah and
alright Brett's confirming that for me
now interestingly Mia has been pretty
outspoken in her own defense so we've
got a couple tweets from her so this is
after someone created an image of what
appears to be an Isis fighter beheading
her she wrote congratulations
middle-east what the threats have
resorted to and obviously you can see
someone who's saying coming soon she
also does in the Middle East have more
important things to worry about besides
me how about finding a president or
containing Isis and someone tweeted at
her your head will be cut soon inshallah
long as it's not my tits they were
expensive so she's having some fun with
this she's defending herself again she
no longer lives in Lebanon she lives in
the United States so she's using her
freedom of speech anyway the whole point
this story I think is sort of that I
think that porn this is what could solve
the Middle East its problems if these
people wouldn't be so sexually repressed
yeah it would actually help
is this a 748 years younger the religion
is that Christianity they're like they
just haven't been mature mature into
immaturity Yeah right now they're being
very mature right now they're being like
we're sticking to our rules in our guns
and this is what we do and we're not
going to give an inch it's a very
teenage response yeah now they need to
get into like oh I can I can masturbate
it's fine yeah no I'm not gonna kill
anybody in in fact it makes me feel
better so actually is that part of it
because people always say this that
Christianity which is older than Islam
it went through its really terrible
period so this is only the natural
extension of religion sort of what's
happening right now the natural
progression of religion yeah be like you
know what we all masturbate Yeah right
like to be really feel fearful of it and
then eventually be like oh yeah it's a
Catholicism till today to get a cool
Pope till right before we started this
show they you know came okay yeah I mean
we had they were really yeah I'm not
counting but we had really
cool Pope's back in the day they were
like sleeping around and doing all that
stuff but they were also like denying
denying and doing terrible things yeah
but like now you got some time now
that's only that's not to say that at
all Muslims are like that of course it
cetera but like this this arm of it is
just so so insane yes stop it but that I
look I think there would be if someone's
doing Jesus porn and for all those nun
porn things maybe not death threats but
definitely like Jesus porn oh sure I'm
sure there is I'm sure there is but this
is another rule of porn if you ask the
question is there blank point the answer
is already yes right and that's sort of
why I wanted to do this segment on this
show cuz we started with the thing in
France and we just talked about Isis and
this story it's this is so obviously
linked to me that if people aren't free
sexually and can get their sexual [ __ ]
out in in an appropriate way
but then that's that's fertile ground I
think that's what Bill Maher says it's
fertile ground for extremism right yeah
absolutely fertile you like the fur
seriously though but joking aside this
girl is extremely brave don't you think
like as a female and as someone that's
public and putting her stuff out there I
mean at first it's always the first
person to do something like this is
going to see a lot of resistance and a
lot of danger and thread and it's not
fair to be like oh she represents
Muslims and she's degraders
she's one person and you know what she's
an American and I support that no and
she's the number one person and I say
she's the number one person on pornhub
because I think someone retired what
yeah that was the thing is like some was
their real it was a Christian porn star
it was like I need to pass it on and now
she's the number one person on porn up
and she's blown up like overnight
yeah she's gotten like like a day ago
she had 70,000 Twitter followers now she
has a hundred thousand by the time this
goes up who knows
yeah but she's also going to come stay
with us when she comes to Los Angeles
she's tweeted it's because we tweeted
out or my girlfriend and I said yeah
definitely she's gonna come hang out
with us you know any times you should
come in that sense yeah my hungry times
and once I did not subconscious very on
that note Mia Khalifa I would love to
have you on the show so let us know so
we talked about this a bunch but it
seems to me that
wants it every which way on marijuana in
December he did something pretty good he
basically told the Justice Department
that the feds will no longer get
involved with the states rights related
to medical marijuana okay that's pretty
solid then just a couple days ago he had
the Department of Justice filed a
defense of marijuana's classification as
a Schedule one drug that is the same
classification that heroin has we've got
a statement from the assistant attorney
general this is Gregory Broderick he
said this psychoactive addictive drug is
not accepted as safe for medical use at
this time even with medical supervision
so you really need to kind of wrap your
brain around what's going on here the
states are passing this thing one at a
time it's happening just like a marriage
it's all good there are people that have
cancer and AIDS and all kinds of other
diseases that are using this for
medicinal purposes and they're not
having all the horrible side effects
that all the Big Pharma drugs are giving
them then Obama's on one hand saying
okay the feds aren't going to get
involved and then on the other hand is
saying the complete reverse what that
quote is the complete reverse of what
the actual facts and science are I
really don't understand this about
President Obama and I think this is
something where he is failed epically
actually because it's such terrible
mixed messaging please explain to me
what he's up to you well what he's up to
is hopefully is that thing that your
parents do or your your like he's like
don't you know I'm gonna say this but
like when it's just us hanging out that
I'll tell you what I really feel so in
terms of the camera go we at the federal
government believe that marijuana is
terrible for reasons of probably
elections and voting okay cut all right
so if you want to smoke weed smoke we
just don't get caught that's what it is
and I get it and that's what he did with
gay marriage before he came around with
gay marriage because everyone knew he
was okay with it but awkward but this is
completely backwards can we just draw
the quote up for one more second because
it's really important to understand what
he's having
his people say this psychoactive
addictive drug is not accepted as safe
medical use at this time even with
medical supervision I mean I know people
that are using marijuana for medical
reasons and also I know plenty of people
that smoke pot
ever truly never him to correct me in
the comments section I've never seen
someone addicted to pot now George
Carlin used to do something about how
you know one day most people that smoke
pot they're like all right I'm done
smoking pot and they stop smoking pot or
they're like you know what I smoke pot
every day now I'm gonna smoke it once a
month and so what I just don't get so
what is it this is about votes cuz the
votes are showing that most people
actually at this point are okay with
medical marijuana so what is he up to
lobbying interests I mean the the
article you gave me was I think
equivocating marijuana to heroin well
that's what the Schedule one
classification that's what they're doing
aren't prostituting themselves over pot
and quitting their jobs and losing their
families and ravaging their health and
their appearances it's it's I am Doritos
but just be very clear that's not from
this yeah but just be very clear that's
not from the article that I'm sending
you that's the way the government is
classifying it so that's the government
yeah it's so weird well if this is
there's other ways to interpret this
because there a lot of people were
trying to get into the medicinal
marijuana growing industry yeah and the
recreational drug industry like people
in Colorado and in Washington the
problem is like for them they're like
yeah we're allowed to grow it we're
allowed to sell it the money we get from
it we can't put in banks because of all
the federal laws right all of that it
still can be construed in the opposite
way which is Obama is telling us that
it's okay for the states do what you
want but there's another way to
interpret it where it's like he's
telling us that but he's still trying to
end medicinal marijuana use and
recreational drug use a bad way getting
him at the bank's right precisely so
that quote right there is a direct
attack on medicinal marijuana so he's
pretending that he's being cool with
marijuana not just the recreational side
but he's actually attacking the
medicinal side and that's the part that
I just simply don't understand honestly
I think that's a way to win the battle
against Obama is just kind of be like
guilt him into being like I thought we
were cool buddy you know and she'd be
like you used to be the cool dad and now
you're being kind of a dick so is truly
what's going on here that Big Pharma
which obviously gives a lot of money to
politicians and nobody's above being
bought and even as a second term
president with only two years left that
he's still at the whim of people that
have given him a lot
money and since there isn't big money
yet behind weed I think there will be
and especially as it gets passed more
recreationally and eventually Starbucks
or somebody's gonna come in and you're
gonna be able to get weed in it at a
chain store but until then the
politicians we provide the other way I
mean look at look at heroin right heroin
is classified as a class yeah which is
like I mean try to keep to a schedule
after you've done heroin right but the
but but then you can still get morphine
morphine as a pharmaceutical version of
it that's okay sorry by saying medicinal
marijuana maybe he's distinguishing from
whatever synthetic you know THC
derivative is gonna be sold by Eli Lilly
and Merck and the people who are paying
for that statement to get right all
right so final thought on this you don't
smoke weed right no do you fear weed no
and you fear that someone that is sick
that is smoking weed to help themselves
that that's somehow gonna fringe on your
personal rights or destroy your life
well this segment is ending right there
you see what you did a 72 year old
grandmother has shocked her friends and
some of her family by announcing that
she's in love with her grandson yeah
that's right there they are the cute
couple oh lordy lordy yes she's in love
with her 26 year old grandson and they
released a statement about their love
here's just some info first her daughter
put him up for adoption when she was 18
years old when she passed away he
tracked down his long-lost grandmother
and they quickly fell in love so that's
how this all came to pass so she didn't
know him for the first 18 years so that
makes it a little better I suppose and
here's what grandma said from the first
moment that I saw him I knew we would
never have a grandmother grandson
relationship for the first time in years
I felt sexually alive well I feel dead
inside I mean this is the creepiest
thing yeah I see a lot of creepy stuff
yeah I'll intentionally go on the
internet and look for creepy weird
things this creeped me out I mean more
than most things I've ever seen yeah so
we see look we do all kind of stories on
horrible torture awful things that
people are doing to each other and we do
play
on some weird sexual stuff we just did a
segment on the the maskers and people
that are putting themselves in silicon
women's bodies all but this is like this
is sort of the height of yeah of low
yeah yeah I mean that is that is
different than having a kink listen we
all love grandma everybody loves Graham
no it does it makes great cookies oh
absolutely go to our house maybe she'll
knit you a sweater yeah but don't [ __ ]
grandma please open it's ruining many
childhood memories for me and maybe
that's selfish but honestly I he's it's
weird though because they're because
they used a surrogate to get pregnant
you know only his genetic material and
the surrogates genetic material I can't
mix grandpa first up grandma's eggs are
and gone gone gone the way of the dodo
you're not gonna get a good young egg
from Grandma
yeah you shouldn't be given any seed but
so so morally all it is is them doing it
right which is just it alright but Kim
should we not judge lest we be judged or
whatever that phrase is right like if
they're not there's no scientific reason
that this baby's not gonna be okay so if
if he wants to bang grandma grandma
wants to bang him
shouldn't we be okay with them making
their own pearl a libertarian probably
would be okay with that you shouldn't
progressive okay I mean there's just a
bit much maybe psychologically wrong
there what happened yeah yeah yeah I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna stop him from
doing it I'm just going to try to
convince him not to yeah I'm going to
use my free speech to say you shouldn't
[ __ ] your own grandma but I mean um this
wouldn't be America if he wasn't allowed
to you know what I never thought we'd
have to end this segment on this but you
shouldn't [ __ ] your own grandma okay New
York City my hometown wants to stop the
spread of man spreading what is man
spreading what we've got some photos
that will illuminate you man spreading
yeah there it is it is when these guys
it's usually about guys which is why
they're calling man's ring really
sitting with the legs really really why
look at the look on his face - he's very
excited that yeah and it's putting your
bags on other seats or
the floor blocking off now that one I
thought was particularly odd because
there's nobody else near him so that
that time it's okay but generally this
feeling of New York City the subways are
very over packed there right now they're
building the second Avenue subway which
they've been trying to do for like 20
years or something but especially on the
east side the subways are always packed
and these guys that just sit out there
and bags everywhere and all that stuff
so they're trying to stop it and there's
a new poster that is telling people what
to do dude stop the spread please it's a
space issue I thought this was kind of
interesting because it is getting a
little blowback people are like they're
interfering with our rights we can do
whatever we want blah blah blah and you
know common courtesy you know my sister
is seven months pregnant in New York
City I was skyping with her last night
she was telling me how half the time
guys don't even get up you know she's
like extremely pregnant big girl and
they still like it's just so I just
thought this was kind of you know do we
need to litigate these things or is it
just common decency it's just rude and
selfish I mean if I were to put my purse
on the seat and my jacket on the seat
you would ask me to move them and you
would be right to do so because I don't
own the train it's a public space and I
should do what is fair and allotted for
me yeah
what's the worst thing you ever saw done
on the New York City Subway or on any
sort of transit thing because I've seen
some pretty my favorite thing that's
ever happened on it on public
transportation is a bunch of kids
fighting over a picture and word up
Magazine of Chris Brown what I don't
know that's just that's incidental but
that probably every day there was like
it was like what are they fighting over
that's my Chris Brown poster that's
right I'm gone but I on public
transportation I've definitely seen
videos of like drunken people getting
and I've seen personally like drunken
people passed out sprawled on the
backseat like three across and then
afterwards they had to pull the person
out of the thing like totally drunk but
other than that like I had to
demonstrate for my girlfriend yesterday
I was showing her this this story and
it's a real thing like I can't sit with
my legs like this unless I do like a big
like you're doing now I'm not you are
I'm building it together but I just did
the flipping before if you don't do the
flippy you're and then is this a test
wait what are you saying so you say
you sit down naturally your legs fly a
lot of the photos were except a lot of
these are [ __ ] but like I'm sitting
like this so my legs are going out
that's not manspreading let's do I have
to do a whole like series of motions so
you know it's to do that so if if there
is someone that needs to sit I'm gonna
do all those motions it's gonna look
weird but then I'll get in position
where I can sit like with my legs you
know
parallel to each other that said I think
the whole idea of we're gonna put up
signs that helps but you can still like
look at someone I mean this is people in
public transportation trying to say like
I don't make me look at them and go can
you please let me sit down right so
that's why I thought this story was
interesting because the I look it's not
a law they're not passing a law you're
not gonna get fined if you spread your
junkie and I get it fine although one
time actually speaking of spreading drug
I did see a guy like an old man in
running shorts and he had no underwear
on his balls were just literally on his
old balls were just on the subway then
yeah just on the chair just like that
boy I don't think he knew like I don't
know I don't think he was a pervert or
breeze at all he does that old ball he
was cooling off his old balls but
actually that wasn't even the worst
thing that I saw on the subway the worst
thing I ever saw on the subway
was on a packed New York City morning
commute there was a woman clipping her
fingernails I mean literally they were
just flying everyone's looking at her
and in a weird way I admired her I was
like if I could ever be so detached and
not give a [ __ ] to the point that this
woman I give way too much of a [ __ ] this
woman doesn't give a [ __ ] and she's
getting [ __ ] done
beside yourself for once
especially if you're in public that's
what the sign is for try and not be a
nuisance you were not the only one here
really there's a new there's a new line
there's a new like Expo line or
something and people on this stretch
have never used light rail before
because it's new it hasn't gotten there
so what I saw when it first opened up
was a lot of people that are like the
opposite like everyone staying as far
away from each other as possible and
like they're like looking around it's
this new thing I'm afraid of everything
here right if you go to a city with like
a lot of people on public transportation
it's the opposite it's
everyone is so like in it and their
personal space ideas are just completely
out the window and it's as though they
don't notice other people around them
yeah if you don't live in New York City
and you've never been to New York City
and you want to know a little bit about
the craziness subway find the episode of
Seinfeld that Elaine is trapped
they're all on the subway in that
episode but Elaine is by herself trapped
on the subway and it's a perfect example
of how crazy the subway is but my final
thought on this is that how much of this
do you think is just a culture of sort
of the selfie and our followings like
we're all so into our own [ __ ] all the
time that I don't think people really
even realize when they're in a public
space like you're describing they're in
a transit thing and they're so still in
it so they don't even realize what their
body's doing you see this all the time
videos of people falling into fountains
do they have their heads now like it's
just part of that culture that well you
know we're definitely in our in our own
[ __ ] all the time but if you want to get
in other people's literal [ __ ] ride the
subway yeah yeah but yeah we're we're
definitely abled now it used to be you
get a like a nag magazine or a paper and
you're doing that and then you're but
everyone knows who's around them and you
do this thing where you like turn away
and lean so the other person like that
backs up and gets away from you but
close your legs if you're on the subway
that's it Gallup did their
end-of-the-year worldwide survey of 65
countries 64 thousand people to find out
if people were happy with their lives
and we've got some findings Fiji is the
happiest country in the world 93 percent
of people in Fiji said they were happy
while Iraq is the least happy I guess
that's no surprise they're only 31
percent Iraqis are happy 70 percent of
people worldwide say they are happy with
their life up from 60 percent last year
I think that's fascinating Wow 42
percent believe that next year we'll be
one of economic prosperity for their
country and just 12 percent of Western
Europeans believe that 2015 will be a
year of economic prosperity so let us
start with the end of that there so it's
42 percent thinking that economic
prosperity is coming to them seems
pretty wide-eyed to me and yet Western
Europeans so we're talking about France
and England Spain they don't think that
what's going on there
I don't know I mean it's it's so all
over the map all this other statistics
it just depends on how people felt when
you ask them that right I mean I'd like
to see to take a look miss bonus that
day you're feeling a little better yeah
yeah but one of economic prosperity I
just feel like there's probably in
Western Europe things have been pretty
shitty lately and so I think they're
just thinking it'll go through and then
I don't know I'd like to see like a map
of the world to see where people are the
happiest I liked it like an island
nation right of course Fiji we get it
93% you're a Fiji like how are you not
happy if you're on yeah they're pretty
good I think I've never been to Fiji
water those bottles the square bottle
it's very nice it's very about could we
just go back to image one more time for
a quick second so the other part that I
thought was interesting is that seventy
percent say they're happy with their
life which is up from sixty percent last
year so that means you know we hear this
all the time that everything's so shitty
and we've talked about a bunch on the
show lately how it seems like
everything's awful because we're so
connected so we can all see the horrible
things that are happening about all the
time but actually maybe things aren't
that terrible yeah it's good to see that
70% of the people are like despite all
the [ __ ] I've seen yeah it's gonna be
okay yeah that's good I wonder if they I
mean that seems like you can round you
know that's that's that's encouraging
that that might be like the default
human setting yeah it's like that'll be
better next time to actual prosperity I
think is having a good attitude and you
know pushing for more but at the same
time we also at least you know maybe in
the u.s. we have this feeling that you
know don't get content with anything
keep pushing for more do you better get
more get get the next thing but do you
think we have a little bit of that
Western European thing going on the
United States there definitely is a
sense here I think that our best days
are kind of behind us which is also
almost like a self-fulfilling prophecy
in a way like if you start thinking it
yeah I don't think it's actually the
case back in the day yeah I mean it is
getting a little bit better at least
socially yeah I think a lot of people
would probably argue with that but I
think that probably that's probably you
still have huge problems clearly it's
better than slave days I know it's
better than that and you know and Obama
says that too it's like it's better it's
not perfect but like come on yeah I I
did think that was interesting when
Obama said this week about how race
relations are better now and then he was
getting such [ __ ] for it and it's like I
get it there is bad stuff going on but
it's way better than it was so much it
just that doesn't mean the police are
doing the right thing I could just all
of it oh yeah we're no one's resting on
their laurels here but like let's put
things in perspective there's are those
things where like what kind of teacher
do you want do you want the teacher
who's like no it's terrible all the time
life sucks and we got to get better or
the one who's like okay yes there's here
the areas we can improve on but like I
also want you to know that you're making
progress yeah and I know it doesn't feel
that way for everybody and that's fine
but like you know we we're still
improving and what shows how much more
we can improve is the fact that we've
improved so let us acknowledge that
right because if you don't acknowledge
it then it's hard to move forward and I
think we we do get lost in that final
thought of this what is your definition
of happy came Horcher uh being
personally fulfilled in my career I
think that's it career you're good to go
I I feel like there might be part of me
broken cuz I don't really got at this
point I don't give a [ __ ]
let's make this career happen Wow
alright Brett me I'm manspreading right
now I got to the point where it was so
uncomfortable I had to man spread he is
if you don't know what man spreading is
we just did a segment on it annotation
right there he is sitting with his legs
wide open what makes me happy
it's if you comment and like right down
below so the New York Times just
published a piece that I thought was
kind of fascinating about kids spies
yeah full-on kids
spas places called things like sweet and
sassy and seriously spoiled salon and
spa
yeah that sounds just awful and
literally they are targeting kids I'm
talking about seven-year-old kids
they're giving them facials they're
offering kid-friendly music banana
scented facials they're driving around
and live
and of course they use age-appropriate
vocabulary customers are princesses and
toes are pigley's yeah so look at this I
mean look I don't know how well let's
say those girls are maybe 10 12 or so if
you are 12 years old and you need to put
cucumbers on your eyes these are not the
kids that need that [ __ ] these are those
pampered princesses on the planet I mean
this is literally going on in New York
City right now yeah so I thought this
was interesting because we live in a
time where we you know we always talk
about the 1% even though it's really the
0.1% and this middle class is
disappearing and the huge lower-class
that's expanding and it's like wow
people could be so detached yeah that
you're sending your kids you're already
pampered kids who go to private school
and have every advantage on earth and I
don't begrudge them any of that but then
you're sending them for cucumber facials
we have something we need to learn that
we need to like teach limit from a young
age parents are going I want them to be
shitty early I want to teach them how to
be shitty right out of the bat and I
like it it's like oh these cucumbers
take ten years off your face you look
like you're beat yeah you look like
you're negative six yeah you look like
your dad's balls and in a weird way are
these people setting up their kids for
like a really horrible life in a weird
way because there's a good chance that
these kids will not be as successful as
their parents so when they're eight
years old and they're getting facials
and being driven around in limos there's
a good chance that they're gonna be less
well-off economically than their parents
and they're gonna go [ __ ] what I was
eight those were the good old days I was
having candy yeah a trust fund which you
probably do they probably do have a
trust but they absolutely have a trust I
was trying to find some silver lining
here there's there's there's no silver
lining today's I hate to break this to
you I hate to burst that I hate to rain
on your parade with this shitty truth
which is these kids are going to be bad
unless there's that moment where they're
like oh my god I'm I can't believe I'm
I'm this terrible or maybe if the
parents are smart and it you know they
probably won't sell them to the spa but
if these parents are smart they're like
here here is living well okay so we're
gonna take you to the spa now to justify
that
we're also gonna make you work we're
gonna show you what we do in order to
provide these nice things right and I'm
pretty sure that's not going on I'm
pretty sure what this was making me
think was when I was a kid and I was
maybe 10 or 12 like I remember I really
really wanted to have a birthday party
at Chucky Cheese like I had a couple of
birthday parties at bowling alleys and I
was like this year I want Chucky Cheese
and I remember that was like a I think
it did end up happening but like it was
a struggle to make that happen with my
parents you know that was gonna cost
more blah blah blah but I wanted Chucky
Cheese Chucky Cheese happened god bless
him but like just how different you know
it I mean like everybody grows up in
such a different thing I'm sure someone
else would have grown up thinking that a
bowling birthday party wouldn't be the
greatest thing it's all relative it's my
point yeah and it's so easy yet such ed
Murray what was your Chucky Chucky yes
was Chucky Cheese you've got Chucky
Cheese what was something that you
wanted really bad that you had to like
work for there was like a big like
compromise made was like all right we'll
give it to you like you know you need to
dress like you're cool when you're in
elementary and middle school and those
clothes are expensive and your parents
are like hell no so it's like okay you
can have an allowance but you have to
work for it you can buy it your damn
self you know it's funny I remember in
like sixth grade or something champion
t-shirts just a simple champion t-shirt
was like the coolest thing you could
have and all my friends had like 10 of
them different colors every day I had
two champion shirts I warm every other
day I had a blue one and a red one and
that was my spot that was my personal
spa and I was happy yeah me just a
beluga caviar mom that shitty run of the
mill whatever the [ __ ] caviar you're
giving me bars oh god that's so hard you
surf I'd like to thank the beluga caviar
of guests brett erlich and Kim [ __ ]
true their twitters are right down below
don't forget to Like comment subscribe
all that other stuff and you guys want
to hit the spa yeah let's do it let's do
it meet so some of the kids and hit the
spot all right let's go
[Music]